uh i really want to start with the
congratulations this movie is what i
call awesome
uh i have nothing but positive things to
say and that's all i have uh you guys
have a fantastic day thanks so
much talking to you that's great great
mustache it's a good pandemic mustache
we like it
being serious john it was pre-covered on
a red carpet in london that i was asking
you about top gun talking to years ago
so
this has been you know you so for all
three of you what has it been like
waiting for this movie to come out
because it's a fantastic movie that's
just been sort of sitting there waiting
well the anticipation leads to more
excitement i think so i think that's the
what was
what was a pot on simmer is now a pot
that's at full boil so i think
when when they finally take the lid off
this thing it's gonna it's gonna really
blow up in the best possible way so i i
literally can't and i'm not speaking for
uh my friends here but i i can't i can't
uh tell you how excited i am and i think
people will also be uh
duly rewarded for their patience
for all three of you guys uh i love tom
cruise he is a true movie star willing
to go above and beyond what anyone else
is willing to do
i really would like to know what if
anything surprised you about working
with him and seeing his work ethic up
close
um you know for me uh it was really his
his just you know and i don't even know
why this should be a thing but his
astuteness with every part of the
filmmaking process you know i think tom
is not just a movie star he's also a
student of filmmaking
student of all the things that make the
movie great i've often said in
interviews that
part of his job is almost being a roller
coaster director just to make sure that
we have
great thrills and chills and turns and
spills and drops this movie has it all
and so you know definitely watching that
up close and personal uh is something
i'll never forget two things struck me
one is uh how
normal he
behaves once you're inside the ropes i
call it once you get past the camera and
your people aren't
around and it's just you and the other
actors he's amazingly normal and it's
like he's hosting a dinner party and he
wants to make sure everybody's having a
good time and everybody has what they
need that's what set feels like so you
feel empowered and like equipped to do
what you want to do and then his energy
on top of that is constantly keeping you
that's what amazed me his his ability to
keep everybody in every department
engaged and enthusiastic about what we
were doing which
in turn appears on the screen so it's
just
amazing
yeah well i you know i'll say this he
had just come off of mission
six
where he broke his ankle
uh doing a stunt where
he broke his ankle that was like
probably the best way that that stunt
could have failed because the worst way
would have been he could have died
uh and like he came off of that with a
with a with a busted ankle and and and
right into this and you would have not
known that had you not read about it in
on collider or wherever you read it you
know it was he was ready to go first guy
on the set last guy to leave
as charles says his enthusiasm is
infectious
it's just he is excited to make
movies and there is something about that
that feels like almost like a relic of a
different time
just a person who exudes this this
enthusiasm for
making movies and it's so it's in every
frame of this movie it is just
an exciting as we share saying
rollercoaster ride that that also hits
you right in the fields too i mean it
really does it it gets it hits all the
notes and uh it was the pleasure of my
career to actually work on this thing my
last thing for you i really loved
claudio cinematography uh can you talk a
little bit about working with him and
what you took away from seeing some of
the visuals in the movie there's a there
there's you know the the technology
of the camera work in this is
unprecedented uh the way that they shot
this and the ability of them to to move
the sony camera that they used has the
ability to sort of remove the body from
the lens so you can kind of put the lens
anywhere and it's attached by wire
so there's
the ability to get shots that have never
been seen before especially in the
aerobatic sequence and the aerial
sequences
is
i think gonna really make people's jaws
drop you see you've seen a couple of the
examples in the trailer but the actual
experience of watching the film is going
to
uh is is really going to uh open
people's eyes and and that's that's 100
claudio and joe the director like
everybody was on the same page of really
delivering a
an unprecedented experience uh visually
that note i need to stop i'm just going
to say can't wait to see fletch and you
guys have a fantastic afternoon i just
had to plug that movie because i can't
wait um thanks guys
you